es hora de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América de France 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio me compañero
Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar con la alerta que lanzó la voz
de sobre una probable crisis de deuda a
nivel global y es que en su más reciente
informe sobre las expectativas de deuda
soberana afirma que las emisiones brutas
y metas van a aumentar en los próximos
años señalan que de casi la mitad de la
deuda negociable de la ocde unos 23
billones de dólares vencerán y deberán
refinanciarse en los próximos tres años
luego de la enorme endeudamiento que
provocó la pandemia del coronavirus en
2020 los países de la oc habían logrado
reducir su pasivo pero el panorama
cambió tras la guerra en Ucrania que
pasa la factura económica la ocde prevé
que las necesidades de endeudamiento de
sus miembros van a crecer alrededor del
6% pero ese 6% representa 12,9 billones
de dólares que el club de los países más
ricos va a tener que pedir prestado a
los mercados financieros el entorno
económico ahora es diferente al de la
pandemia los bancos centrales no solo
están subiendo los tipos de interés sino
que también están dejando de comprar
deuda el secretario general de la ocde
Matías corman dijo que este año marcaría
el final de un largo periodo de
condiciones de financiamiento favorable
para los emisores soberanos a medida que
se adaptan a estas nuevas realidades y a
un entorno de Mercado de rápida
evolución es posible que esta crisis o
esta posible crisis de deuda que señala
la ocde sería dañina especialmente para
los países emergentes como aquí en
América Latina pues Tendremos que estar
muy pendientes al respecto y también
Hablamos de deuda pero ahora
puntualmente en Estados Unidos por estas
reuniones y este debate sobre el aumento
del límite de endeudamiento las
negociaciones no han rendido un acuerdo
avanzan muy lentamente cuál sería el
impacto de un impago de parte de Estados
Unidos bueno las pérdidas económicas
irían desde las fábricas chinas que
venden productos electrónicos en ese
país hasta los inversores suizos que
poseen bonos del tesoro estadounidense
analizadas de uris concluyen que incluso
si el límite de la deuda se incumpliera
durante no más de una semana la economía
estadounidense se debilitaría tanto que
aproximadamente
1,5 millones de puestos de trabajo
desaparecerían pero si el impago se
prolonga más de una semana el
crecimiento económico de Estados Unidos
se hundiría desaparecería en alrededor
de 7,8 millones de puestos de trabajo
también subirían los tipos de interés
abruptamente y la tasa de desempleo
pasaría del 3,4% actual al 8% esto sin
mencionar Valentina el colapso del
mercado bursátil que borraría
aproximadamente unos 10 billones de
dólares la deuda de Estados Unidos es
considerada desde hace muchísimo tiempo
como un activo Ultra seguro y es la base
del comercio mundial un posible impago
podría destruir el mercado de la deuda
del que está valorado actualmente en 24
billones de dólares la crisis sería no
sólo en Estados Unidos de todas las
reservas de Divisas que poseen los
bancos centrales del mundo los dólares
de Estados Unidos representan el 58%, el
segundo es el euro con 20% y el tercero
el John chino que representa menos del
3% según el fondo monetario
internacional y eso es algo que saben
los republicanos y también la Casa
Blanca pero que cada día que pasa se
acerca esta fecha límite para tocar el
impago Aunque el congreso ya ha
aumentado ha revisado o ha ampliado este
límite de endeudamiento al menos 78
veces desde 1960 bueno Y tenemos que
estar también muy pendientes al respecto
Jorge el gigante estadounidense de los
semiconductores micron o Michael no
superó un examen de China Bueno de hecho
el gobierno chino pidió a los operadores
de infraestructuras críticas e
información que dejen de comprar sus
productos pero para muchos expertos Esto
hace parte del nuevo capítulo de la
guerra por los chips entre Estados
Unidos también china en la que
Washington Busca vetar a Beijing a los
semiconductores de Última Generación
desde marzo de este año china ya ha
realizado una revisión de los productos
vendidos en el país por Michael uno de
los principales fabricantes de chips del
mundo esto es un golpe duro para la
empresa americana porque alrededor del
10% de los 3.800 millones de dólares en
ingresos anuales al menos en 2022
procedieron justamente de China según
los datos aunque esta guerra por los
chips Lleva años empeoró el año pasado
cuando Estados Unidos impuso
restricciones al acceso de China a chips
de alta gama a equipos de fabricación de
chips y también a programas utilizados
para diseñar estos semiconductores que
son esenciales para bajar la ventana de
tu vehículo para encender las luces para
todo para todo en todo el día hablamos
ahora de cambio climático y de su
impacto económico Jorge y es que en los
últimos 50 años los fenómenos climáticos
extremos causaron pérdidas de casi 4.300
millones de dólares en la economía
global esto según datos de la
organización meteoro mundial en su
último que afirma que en el último siglo
se registraron aproximadamente unos
11.700 desastres climáticos e
hidrológicos que causaron el
fallecimiento de al menos dos millones
de personas en todo el mundo el 90% de
estas muertes se produjeron en países en
vías de desarrollo mientras que más del
60% de las pérdidas económicas se vieron
afectadas en las economías más
desarrolladas del planeta del mundo es
Asia el continente el que más ha sufrido
el mayor número de muertes asociadas a
estos eventos del cambio climático
seguido de África Europa y América pero
no todas son malas noticias según el
organismo el número de muertes
registradas por desastres meteorológicos
cayó considerablemente y lo atribuye a
la mejora de los protocolos de alerta
temprana en los países bueno menos mal
No todo es negativo ahora hablamos de
Argentina que puso en circulación un
billete de mayor denominación para
combatir la inflación esto funciona
Bueno este billete de 2 a 1000 pesos que
puso en circulación El Banco Central
tiene un valor de unos 4 dólares según
los tipos de cambio paralelos usados ahí
y la tasa oficial serían unos 8,50
dólares para varios economistas y
ciudadanos la medida es insuficiente ya
que muchos piden billetes de hasta 10
mil pesos la devaluación de la moneda
causado pesadillas logísticas a empresas
y bancos en Argentina en los precios al
consumidor subieron un 109% en abril se
trata de la mayor alza desde 1991 justo
cuando ese país salía de una
hiperinflación así es que harán falta
muchos más billetes por supuesto de
mayor denominación Jorge tenemos la
cifra del día positiva o negativa no así
que te voy a dar otra mala noticia esta
tiene que ver con el trabajo infantil
sobre todo al menos un medio millón de
niños se ven obligados a trabajar en
Honduras para subsistir según datos
oficiales del número de niños en
situación de trabajo infantil llegó a
los 411.000 en Honduras pero
World Vision afirma que la cifra es
mayor porque el estado no incluye a los
menores que se de dican al trabajo
oculto O sea al empleo informal o estas
labores domésticas pues Jorge usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
económica aquí en directo a América
Nosotros continuamos con el debate a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
[Música]